hey youtubers is Charlie so Deadpool
spider-man have a long history in the
comics Spidey pool became a thing a long
time ago but one of the most meta things
that they've ever done is basically
switch places Deadpool becomes
spider-man and spider-man becomes
Deadpool so I'm going to explain that
story there is a new round of the
spider-man giveaway going on now - all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video
be sure to click that bell so you don't
miss out on anything
so Deadpool becoming spider-man
spider-man becoming Deadpool there's a
long history of Deadpool cosplaying as
other characters he is the biggest fan
of spider-man Wolverine he name drops
Batman all the time and there's been
some fan art that's had him as Batman
but going all the way back to Deadpool's
first run in the comics he's come across
spider-man eventually they started
teaming up they even got their own title
spider-man and Deadpool so thus Spidey
pool was born out of their friendship
there was a period in the comics when he
was superior spider-man when he was
really Otto Octavius in the body of
spider-man when he really started to
hate on Deadpool but for the most part
they are super bros in Deadpool one time
invoked the super bro code and became
spider-man wore his costume in
spider-man war Deadpool's costume to
take down the chameleon so in Deadpool
annual number two Spider Man keeps
getting shanks by mystery people he
starts attacking random old ladies on
the street thinking them the chameleon
so Deadpool gets a brilliant idea as he
tends to do he's going to chameleon the
chameleon by taking on spider-man's
persona to try and draw him out so even
though spider-man's been kind of a jerk
to him lately just talking about
superior spider-man Peter Parker is back
the real Peter Parker he wants to help
him out super bro code
I'm not going to out someone's secret
identity he even fights off a bunch of
office workers that want a peek under
spider-man's mask so Deadpool is
spider-man does a little bit of crowd
work takes a picture with the pretty
girl finds out that it's the chameleon
and gets ganked again but chameleon gets
away so as he's swinging after him he
starts to notice other people in trouble
so decides that while he is wearing
spider-man's
costume he's gonna do spider-man's duty
and help people out just like he thinks
the Peter Parker would classic
spider-man scenario working his way up
the ladder from purse-snatchers he
senses a bunch of snakes going somewhere
so realizes it's an animal theme villain
classic spider-man so he finds out that
it's the master he's a snake themed
villain totally calls him out on his
stupid plan that he's trying to turn
people at the giant mice to feed his
snake army and says he is the enemy of
dumb and tries to defeat him but
accidentally knocks him into his device
turning him and his snake army into a
giant Godzilla size mouse so even though
Deadpool is enjoying a classic
spider-man themed villain this story is
very much in the style of Deadpool
adventures whereby he starts out with a
very simple problem to solve but in
trying to solve it creates much bigger
problems for himself that he then solves
in hilarious ways so it just snowballs
out of control until he hijacks a
helicopter from the authorities in
throws it at the giant Godzilla Mouse
defeating it but then out comes the
chameleon the person that he was
originally putting on the spider-man
costume to get and then spider-man
resurfaces in the Deadpool costume and
they have a classic Mexican standoff
Clint Eastwood style the chameleon
emulates Deadpool Deadpool is forced to
choose who he shoots
so finally spider-man says you're my
amazing friend
yomo shoots him because he doesn't trust
it and then he finally just decides to
shoot them both and just happens to
shoot the chameleons first so then
spider-man learns that the reason the
chameleon was able to track him is
because of the upgraded web fluid that
Otto Octavius was using when he was
acting as spider-man Deadpool says you
should probably fix that so they take a
lot of opportunities to make fun of
superior spider-man during this so this
concludes amazing friend team-up awesome
Spidey pool story but as you've noticed
they do like to make fun of themselves a
lot anytime they do a story where
Deadpool is doing something above and
beyond his normal level of
ridiculousness they always take as many
opportunities as possible to troll
themselves they did the same thing I did
a video about how they were trolling
Batman V Superman but really it was
Deadpool trolling the Deadpool movie in
Rye
Reynolds so I'll add a link to that in
the comments the closest we've ever
gotten to this actually happening in the
movies was the Deadpool movie where Ryan
Reynolds as Deadpool wore the Hugh
Jackman mask he's such a trooper for
allowing his face to be used in that way
I can't even tell you I deserved that
too no no no no no no maybe maybe not
the nethers start talking the baby's a
guy under this mask he ain't the same
women that you remember you mean this
mask
[Music]
and this one in case the other fell off
but they're really good friends so
technically he wasn't becoming Wolverine
although now Ryan Reynolds is
campaigning behind the scenes to get
Hugh Jackman to do a Wolverine Deadpool
crossover who knows if that'll ever
happen because we're supposedly getting
our very last few Jackman Wolverine
movie in a couple months but I wouldn't
assume anything until it actually goes
down so they'll probably be liberal
Wolverine Hugh Jackman jokes in the
Deadpool sequel and even though the
Logan movie looks pretty freakin serious
there might be some Deadpool in there
somewhere just on the easter-egg level
but in real life you may have seen some
of the funny videos that Ryan Reynolds
and Hugh Jackman have posted back and
forth so I'm gonna play these
back-to-back then I'll explain what
they're from good I might Hugh Jackman
here just reminding you to get your
votes in for people sexiest men alive
covers coming up good eye a good day
good day sorry Ryan Reynolds here I
method actor I'm working on my
Australian accent I'm doing a Crocodile
Dundee 7 are you gonna love it anyway
you may remember me from such things as
People magazine's 2010 sexiest man alive
or the 12th best DC comics movie Green
Lantern who would have thought that just
three days after getting a star on
Canada's Walk of Fame I'd be getting a
star on Hollywood Walk of Fame yep I now
join the ranks of other great Canadians
such as William Shatner Leslie Nielsen
and Tommy Chong how could a guy who
failed his high school drama class be
this talented I have no answer but to
quote my favorite actor in the world the
Great Australian Hugh Jackman and by the
way was people sexiest man alive
way before me Americans are the most
generous country on the planet so
Thank You America and feel free to
urinate on my section of the sidewalk so
you can see that first clip was actually
from when they were still making the
Deadpool movie when Ryan Reynolds was
getting ready to be voted People's
Sexiest Man the other clip is from more
recently with you Jackman giving Ryan
Reynolds a shout-out because he got a
star on the Hollywood Walk of Fame so
that was just a big moment for Ryan
Reynolds career but then you realize
like how come they haven't been doing
this the whole time this would be so
amazing you can make a movie even if it
wasn't a comic book movie which is the
two of them being ridiculous
but because the Logan movie is coming up
and because Hugh Jackman was a total
sport when they were promoting Deadpool
you might see a lot more of this
Deadpool style humor going into March
because that's when the Wolverine movie
is coming but when you start talking
about Deadpool spider-man crossovers in
the movies that's like a long long ways
off Kevin Feige said there's currently
no deal to be made with Fox anytime soon
it sounds like it's more of a fox thing
like they're just not ready to make a
deal with Marvel yet but you have to
remember all the drama with spider-man
at Sony they're all about rebooting the
character starting with something fresh
at Marvel so once that character is a
little more mature once they've got a
couple movies under the belt they'll be
ready for more fun
Deadpool style humor like this but
they're taking it pretty seriously at
the start I mean well be it with like a
Spider Man sense of humor which isn't
quite the same thing as Deadpool but
just like in the comics you start out
with a bunch of characters in their own
titles then Stanley gets the bright idea
to throw them all together and make an
Avengers comic way way back and then
eventually you get deadpool style
crossovers they kind of make fun of that
thing so really in the movies we've had
our first couple big Avengers team ups
eventually you'll get something that
will totally parody that and you'll have
more opportunities for Deadpool
spider-man style crossovers so don't
worry we'll get there eventually it's
just that before you can parody a team
up like that you have to have the
regular team ups first which is actually
where we're headed in Marvel phase 3 and
phase for way more crossovers than you
ever thought we were going to get
there's going to be so much Doctor
Strange in other people's movies expect
the same thing from Ironman just like
he's going to be in the spider-man movie
next but in related news big trailers
maybe draw
paying really soon there have been
rumors that the Justice League trailer
is going to drop really soon so I'll do
a video about Justice League in the next
couple days but new Game of Thrones new
Walking Dead in a whole bunch more
Marvel DC posting next week so if you
want to suggest any comic book
characters becoming other characters
like Deadpool becomes venom the entire
Marvel Universe just became venom they
did a bunch of variant covers so if you
want to recommend a story just write it
below in the comments
begin height there's also going to be a
whole bunch of Star Wars next week - we
got to talk about what's going to be
happening next what you guys wait for
that to post you can click here to watch
the flash fight iris West
and you can click here to rewatch those
spider-man trailers thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight
you